John: Good morning, Hank.
It's Tuesday.
I'm on my way to get a tattoo.
So Hank, I am here outside of Firefly Tattoo
with Rosianna, and I am going to get an inkless
tattoo as a punishment because apparently
in 2012, I did something punishable and then
you and Nerdfighteria dredged it up because
you like to see me suffer.
Slightly off topic, Hank, but I just saw the
television program Firefly for the first time.
It is excellent.
Why did they cancel that?
So this is Laura, my tattoo artist.
I have a couple questions.
Laura: Sure.
John: What is the least painful place to get
an inkless tattoo?
Laura: Anywhere that you've got some good
muscle.
I know you've got some on your arm.
John: My bicep is just huge muscles.
Laura: There you go.
John: Alright, I think I just want it to say
DFTBA on my, uh, on my upper arm.
I actually brought a shirt to change into.
Can you tell I am an anxious person?
Laura: Maybe just a little bit...
John: Are you just gonna... oh this is not
a tattoo this is a pen.
Laura: This is a--this is a marker.
John: Okay.
Laura: Are you familiar?
John: (laughing) Okay, yeah, I've seen those
before.
But you know what I don't even want to look
at that.
I'm scared.
I'm going to be honest, Laura, that hurts
a little bit.
Is it gonna hurt more than that?
Am I the most anxious tattoo recipient you've
ever had in your career?
Laura: You might be, honestly.
John: I'm honored.
Laura: This is very strange not to have any
ink here...
John: Okay, have you ever done an inkless
tattoo?
Laura: No.
John: Oh sweet Jesus.
Laura: We're all trying new things today.
John: Alright.
Oh that doesn't hurt at all.
Laura: I told you.
Hank, I think I might sort of like getting
tattoos.
I feel like I could read a book while this
is happening.
Laura: People do that.
John: Do they really?
John (voice-over): So Hank, Laura made my
DFTBA tattoo with water instead of ink meaning
that it's gonna go away in about a month,
and I have to say that while I spent the last
several weeks fearing this punishment, it
turned out to be the least punishing Vlogbrothers
punishment ever.
In fact, I really love the tattoo itself,
especially in all of its impermanence--I mean,
DFTBA are, after all, the five most important
letters in my life.
Update: Just realized that both of my children
have five-letter names, so I would like to
amend my previous statement.
But anyway, Laura made the whole process relaxing
and fun and pretty painless.
We just chatted for a while and then suddenly--
Laura: That's also done.
John: Are you serious?
Laura: That's it.
John: It's over?
Laura: It's over.
John: Hank, look at my awesome tattoo!
Now I want to get a real tattoo.
Laura: See, I told you.
John: I gotta talk to my wife though first.
I can't believe it's over, that was so fast
and easy and relatively fun--I'm not saying
"get a tattoo," I'm just saying it's fast
and easy and fun--anyway Hank, as it says
on my arm, don't forget to be awesome.
I'll see you on Friday.